Hey, how's it going at Bros my name PewDiePie
Today, I'm recording from my streaming setup because we're gonna play a Life Is a Strange Life Is Strange
It's a very strange. Before the Storm, the new one.
Are you excited? ~Oh my Gaaa'~
I'm excited. I'm really excited for this.
I think it's gonna be a really, really good game. The first episode of the original one,
I really loved so I'm like, well, the first episode they're probably gonna nail on this one as well
Other than that,
Why don't we just get started?
Why don't we just get into this. Can we get one million likes on this video? That would just be *italian kiss* A-Plus.
Okay, so...
I can already pick.. What?
They got three of them out already. I don't believe that. What is happening, am I replaying the original one?
Is that what's happening here? Oh, no.
It's a story based game that features player choice.
Lies, it's always the same ending. Stop lying to me, game.
Oh look, it's the edgy blue hair woman.
She make a smoke,
She goin suicide
Did it fucking say "leet" on the train?
Well done, developers. Well done. Well done, the "leet" train. What the...
Okay, well, that's highly irresponsible and...
Trains come a lot faster than you think. Oh my God. It's not Chloe.
We expect that it would be, because she's the edgy one?
Ah, yes! I remem-
Hahaha I missed the cringe, the cringey dialogue.
It's so good.
*Horrible nasally voice* "My mom would totally kill me if she thought fuck yeah, I am like the edgiest kid ever right now."
All right, we're greeted by this fence, very nice.
We can look, or we can jump, or we can...
Approach the fence, hold down and then press S to jump it and W to..
*horrible nasally voice* "Ah, no way not on my watch, fuck you game, ah facka you, ahahaha!"
Ohh! Shit! She did not do that. Do not flip off sign.
What a dump.
Well..
That's generally how buildings work, Chloe. Or whatever your, I forgot her name. (It's Chloe.)
Maybe we should use this machinery.
I actually really like.. One thing I really liked about this game was the puzzles.
But let's talk to this guy.
Well, you're a whamon. It shouldn't be that hard, okay?
Oh God, anyone that says totally legit is totally not legit.
Man, if you, if you get caught with a fake ID in Sweden,
they'll, they'll call the cops at you.
I suppose, I suppose we just sneak in, to be honest
Yeah, let's burn the place down.
I love that sarcastic tone that she has now, it's really like she developed with their Pewdiepie, watching Pewdiepie
videos. You know.
Oh you can tag? Oh, that's awesome.
"Now, what to draw..."
Not a meth lab
Free candy, that's pretty funny
Well, they're both pretty funny. I got it, Breaking bad reference
"Hey kids! Free Candy." Oh God
the cringe
Man, I used to tag when I was a kid
stupid
But also some of the most fun I ever had "This place has collected a lot of junk over the years."
All right, well fuck it, I don't. Ponder?
You want to guess. No. I'm not gonna ponder. Maybe I'll talk to these guys
"Those guys need to get a room."
What's with the ugly ass tattoos?
He got a slam
He got a sniper duper
"Seriously, though. Who drives an RV to a Firework show?"
Why is it? I why am I struggling so hard here she talked to the eye again like she said
"God, again? What do you want, kid?"
Your bike "Is that your bike over there?"
"Yup"
"It's, ah... pretty cool."
"Gee, thanks... is that all?"
Oh, that worked out well
You started a backtalk challenge. What what is that? Okay? All right
"I have to convince this doorstop, that I'm not giving up until he lets me inside."
In fact, I'll use arguments and insults to get.. Man, what happened, you've changed girl
"Don't you remember what it's like to be a teenager? I just want to see the band!"
"I thought we went over this. Isn't past your bedtime?"
Her name is Chloe. Okay, so
Bedtime yes to proceed pay attention to where your opponent says okay? He he said bedtime okay? No, it's not bedtime
It's your bedtime
"Aww, isn't it past yours?"
"Real cute. But I still don't know you."
Cute, OK, alright, is it cute?
I don't do cute, cute is relative. What could it? What could it hurt? What does that mean?
Cute is relative. I don't do cute. I don't do cute!
"Look at my face. Do I look cute? Or do I look like I'm going to  kick your ass?"
"Ok kid. I get it, you're tough."
This isn't a playground. Fine, I'll sneak in. I am not a kid.
"Maybe I'm a kid, because this place looks like a damn playground to me." Oh
"A girl like you... I can't protect you in there."
A girl like me? "You mean a girl who doesn't take shit from a walking pair of biceps like you?
That kind of girl?"
"My boss will kill me if I let you in."
"Bosses suck. Screw the man and copulate the rules, dude!
Oh my God...
"You're not accepting no for an answer." This is how it works in real life by the way
"And you really think you can take me?"
"Yep."
"What i I had a knife?"
"No problem."
"A gun?"
"Don't care."
You could have a flamethrower, an army of robot ninjas and a motherfucking dragon on a leash in there, and I'd still kick your ass
"I give up!"
"You're alright, kid. Go on in."
Yep, that's how that's how it works
That's that's that's how reality works. Wow I feel so immersed oh
Oh. My. Gaaawd!
We made it inside!
"This is intense!" *wtf why do I keep quoting the subtitles, someone delete it plz*
Delia Come Aunt Delia
That's pretty cool fourth tier
Question everything why?
It's this place sucks all the lights and the sound can't wait to get in there and thrash
Half those stairs our product through looks dicey, okay? Well let's get a drink it says t-shirt
20 bucks baby 20 bucks. That's robbery and don't call me baby. Fine 20 bucks 'if
That guy's a dick
if I want a shirt
I'm going to need to get creative what you mean you want to steal matt guy is such an asshole
I have to steal the cheetos and let me steal eight shirts a
knife
sweet knife
Just like the one my mom refused to get me for my birthday
Yeah, just like the one my stupid mom would it get me a guy what the hell happened?
Okay, all right I
You spin my head right round right round when you go down sit and spin
Okay, no, I saw it. Thank you. Oh, God
Push through here we go
Just blend in Felix
Come on. Like a drunk guy wouldn't care hey you okay. I'm fine
Hey, you don't know who I?
zero shits
That works out for you, bitch
Alright, mosh pit is a No-go fine, really
Maybe I can get a better view of the action from up above why do you want to be here? I don't understand
You want Somebody's bad Druggie?
Look at that getup studs. You're trying to
What are you even doing here? I'm trying to see this
But this place is crazy packed
How'd you even hear about this little shindig?
the internet how else seriously fucking kids
I'm curious about the guy did you see that guy? I ran into acted like I was supposed to know who the hell he was
Yeah, I know
He works for Damon Damon new this is his place. He's
Friend of mine, this is vicious
Alright those stairs go
Frank I mean
Will I get a better view of the band up there? Oh fuck should I know?
More puffs brought it all to hell, okay. No one goes up fine
All right, I don't ask you later, whatever
No, thanks. I tried to avoid hepatitis. What I can
yeah that I try to have are that habit out of that, but I love our brown ah
Chill girl, what's up chill girl? How can you just chill when firewalk is tearing it up in the next move yeah?
It's time to see the band. I'll have to find another way those guys are trouble
I'm a goddess fire walk on out of Rom. How could it my brother Chou?
How can you beat a red shell the spiral is like taller bring up ripped apart?
let curl around
but God
Flavors Like Pilot Pepper olive on
of a garden start Bannerman car
it
I'm just gonna talk in case this is copyrighted music
Material I think it is, so I'm just going to leave
Thank you. I'm gonna go now. Sorry you spilled my beer beach
To replace I don't like your attitude
We're not done
And how about I show you how impressed I am with limp-dick get butter over spilled beer
Is Gonna regret every word every?
This is going
I'm gonna teach this little funky man serious. You want to see me get angry here, because I'm getting there, and it won't be pretty
It won't shoot the chicken, too
What?
What do you call me? Oh?
I gotta choose carefully. What do I do? I attack or run?
This is the moment where I make the wrong decision and everyone's gonna be like oh, you should have you should have
attacked
That's right stand up for yourself
Rachel oh my God is Rachelle
Am I playing the wrong episode as so much has changed? I know what's happening
But what timeline are we in is Dönitz on president?
We don't frank not Gonna have calm down come on walk away
Now stop the music stop Gonna Munich Gonna be a I'm gonna mute. It right
God
This is great. I'm loving this music. It's very good
Okay, I'll thank fucking God Jesus Christ the first episodes got copyrighted I
remember that
It's good music in this reminds me of the old cco. She always had like really good like team type of chill music
Guys watch do see first season was so good
So much attitude so much edge in this one. They really stepped up the edginess man
Love it. I love that. I love Ya, but game again for
Jesus Christ, just wake up sleep
Yeah, it sounds so much like Oc music. They must have been inspired
It's like all everyone listened to it swallowed it when it came out
The last song of the season was so good. Oh the first one
To smoke weed then no one smokes cigarettes like that. I'm not saying that you should whatever
Don't smoke. It's a bad for you
You will get the lung disease and when you are alder you will not be happy about it
Like Elly's weed I can understand smoking
Fucking all I want to do is shut my eyes and tell the world to go to hell
Did you legit become?
Wait, oh my God have I been so confused this whole time
Oh no, did I mix up the two main characters? She doesn't have the blue hair oh?
My God, I've been playing that's chloe it. Took me this long to realize
Max is together girl. Oh my
Yeah
I'm so stupid. I didn't realize until I saw her bedroom
I'm sorry. I am so sorry. I can't believe I thought that
I thought she was old there, and that's why she lick their fresh smell like cigarettes and beer better change clothes
oh my God, I
Really thought it was max. I was like whoa. She really changed, and I thought like something happened. Oh my God. I'm so stupid
Cute so coy nikol Chad okay way, Disney
My not done her what's taking forever? Oh?
I guess we got a punch. Huh why oh here. It says in the bottom. I didn't see it. That's awkward
Whoa, it's so smooth wow
Wow, I really should get going you probably should
Mr.. Sharkey Great, I
sleep
Shit, where's my phone Varis. It's not here. How drunk was I last night
Guess I better try calling my phone my mom's
Okay
Mom's phone is probably in her room. I can use it to call mine, then figure out where the hell. I left it, okay
That make sense let's do it
Let's cigar is that me
Hamari, oh look at this every day and not see what at all she's dating
Well, she does look kind of insane in this picture. I don't know oh
Boy, oh boy. Oh boy
Well at least if you didn't forget to put your phone on charge so that's always
That's always it sounds like my phone is definitely nearby it sounds like I'm a faun. It's in the pooper
Probably like six thousand Cos your Luck's are super popular
I'm a guy who got a new method for Mom
Chloe will you be home by curfew there will be consequences?
Will you be coming home at some point tonight? Nope links well? Oh?
Okay, all right
Wow, yeah, okay? If I if I went out like that, you know so mom's purse in her room
They wouldn't be like hey. We made you breakfast you're welcome. You're welcome
We got your breakfast little snoopy poopie pie
What is this mom's old engagement ring?
It's supposed to be mine. If I'm ever stupid enough to get married. Yeah, so stupid
What sorry why did she say you're stupid pert there? It is like yeah, oh
my God an original pillow
Why don't you get?
that
Really makes me want to hurry
coming mom
Yes, I'm so excited. We're gonna talk it out
We're gonna tell of our feelings express our emotions my purse on the dining table might still have time for breakfast. Sorry I
Am not happy because you divorce a man my father. Oh here I come
This place is a dump you don't water flowers. I would put a purse
here
Chloe I don't have all day would you get over here already mike and see what Mom wants before she strokes my neighbor?
What can I do for you? Huh?
What can I do for you mummy, Mr. Price?
Aka Mom
Great. Hey Mom you wanted to talk
Chloe what happened to you? It's no big deal. I walked into a door you seemed to be walking into a lot of doors lately
Well, you know doors are everywhere man. I send you a text message. Chloe like last night. I need you to answer
You can just say text you don't have to say message, and I need you to answer without the snark
Sorry, I'll do better. Sorry. I hear you. I'll do better about replying
Thank you
Is that what you wanted to talk about?
What is it with you and David always cutting to the chase? Why can't we just have some pleasant conversation before school?
Hugh do realize I hate your boyfriend with every fiber of my being right?
Chloe
You don't hate he calls me girly. He's a dickhole. He can be old-fashioned
Yeah, an old-fashioned dick hole
Okay, let's talk about school, right?
school
My favorite you used to love to learn what yeah I used to think drugs were lame, too
I wish you wouldn't joke like that
That's not fight. I made you breakfast nah. I'll just
Pick something later eat the goddamn breakfast. Oh, you'll enjoy this the other day
I made four eggs two for David two for me and just before I serve them. He says what are you gonna eat?
I'll enjoy that huh tired. Huh that'll teach you to break curfew
What I?
Know what time you came home last night and don't think you can get out of school. Just because you've missed the bus again
Why would you assume that who do you think your principal calls when you skip?
Do you think I enjoyed lying for you saying you're sick just so you don't get expelled
Maybe it's between your grades and your disregard for my rules. I see you slipping
I'm worried, but mom the whole point of lowering expectations is so you won't be disappointed in me?
Never again, you're happy doing what you're doing fine. Keep at it
Just let me know so I can stop fighting with Blackwell to keep you on scholarship
money's tight enough as it is
It's crazy in America. You got a paper school. Maybe I just need to be left alone. Maybe David could help
Maybe David should start paying. God he spends the night often enough. How would you know you're never here yourself?
David thinks you need discipline
Mind his own business. I am I'm own David with this one interest. He's a good man
Maybe he can help yep
Dave Mason was a good man
Dad was a good man. Oh dad was a good but it's not fair. I'm glad your father still has a place in your heart
But sometimes we need to make more room in our hearts for new people and sometimes when we're incredibly desperate and lonely
We choose the absolute wrong kind of people to let into our hearts
Mom
David's had some hard times too. You know if he's kind enough to share his experience
I expect you to listen like I'd let him get within 15 feet of me
Bam
When he takes you to school today very funny. Oh
You will be nice you will be respectful, and you will say thank you. Are you serious?
This is such what Chloe yeah, what such what?
Mom's trying I guess
Maybe I should too, but what's the point in getting along? If it means pretending everything's fine, but it's not
Mom, I know you're dealing with a lot, not that hard at you. I understand you. Don't need me as much anymore
But I need you. I do still need you
You're my mom. I'm proud of you for being so self-sufficient
You're doing real well not out to get you
Tell that to the world you're impossible
But I love you. I love you, too
Mm-Hmm, and my name is Jay David's waiting
You'll need to bring him his keys from the ashtray try not to kill each other got it
Unless he tries to give me advice or looks at me funny. Chloe or looks at me at all
Mom
mom, I know
you to
be
Bad didn't really mean ends is about the most humiliating thing mom could ask me to do oh my God
Bringing the keys. It's the most humiliating thing. I could possibly
think about oh my
oh
my God
Where are they ashtray she's an ashtray? Huh?
motherfuckers there - Tree
Sorry, I'm gonna have to talk to her again cuz I don't understand
Speak come on, sweetheart. I'm sure David's waiting for his keys
That's really helpful
We can't go up again. So they're probably over here soon, right?
Wow
Sean Prescott son Nathan goes to my school it is
here they are I
Found him I found him boys
Thank you
Let's get these to David so he can draw no point in putting off the inevitable torture of driving to school with David
They better get going ya know getting a lift to school nothing could be that bad, right?
Hey, is this Chloe. This is stiff grethe Gran Grish. Hey?
I have your debbie there. Yeah, you can get a before school. I think
my DVD
I
Was I want my DVD back?
What a piece of crap the car to the car looks nice dude
wouldn't want to be driven to schooling that shit that
Had cut his amazement always take forever to get ready. Yeah, well I mean you men will leave without us
No, mom. I swear he beat himself to death with a tire iron. Ha ha
What the fuck don't snap your fingers at me? Is that a black eye no?
Insubordination
Don't wonder your mother's worried about Jim's subordination
When I was your age, I got into my share of scraps
But it's not responsible you owe it to your mother to do better
Tell me again would I owe my mother dirt bag? Yeah, do it did dirt bag?
Got him got rude insulators probably correct
You know what a spark plug does
Yes, it ignites. Do you not hear me? I said I know what it does. I don't know
It's a wood and go grab my socket wrench that from the garage. Did you?
Really there fuck, but I actually don't need all this quality time
Better just get the socket wrench and get this over. Yeah y'all just better to get the both sucker brain suck it up
Max I can't believe I make something man stuff in our garage anyway does he think he's moving in or something?
They're gonna bring it up later
50-50 chance I smashed him in the face with this
60/40
Maybe ninety ten
All right, what is she saying?
It's beautiful. This game is really pretty I like it. It's got a good vibe to it a good atmosphere a
Little more hustle wouldn't have killed you
Oh my God, we're working together as a tam a very nice
you got a sneeze but
See what's coming up the works there? That's a sign of carbon deposits
No, shit. You know you could actually be good at this if you lost the attitude my attitude is what makes me special
David
All right
So you're Gonna drive me let's?
Just Gonna stand there
This is so painful
How long does it go on?
Yes, oh my okay. This is a fucking whatever. That's cute. Oh
Wow, hey, you're taking those tools with you right every house needs a good toolbox
You've already got one, but thanks
Yeah, you called latter tool, but your silly whamming
You don't know anything about our good door, but roll please don't want to talk please don't want to talk
I want to talk to you about something ah
We don't have to like each other
But you will respect me you've enjoyed enough of a vacation from having a father figure
So there are some things I want to be real clear about this guy seems like a lot of fun
You know we're an indoor
Mm-Hmm
choice
Your mother she's hurting chloe hurting for you
You've had it rough no doubt about it, but all this staying out late
ignoring her command
drinking drug use
It's making everything harder
are you using her that matter have one want a pup get your act together and
Put someone else first for a damn change
Am I making myself clear not geez is it crazy if part of what David's saying makes sense to me?
Got it. Thanks. We should really get going
Glad we understand each other
Yeah, anyone have us a conversation with their back turned against you that's always sad a mutual understanding the bow. Oh God. What is happening?
She's waking up what oh in the car
country you're sick
Oh, she's thinking dreaming of her dad
I just called
That's sweet. What a beautiful day
If mom were here, she'd tell him to turn that junk off
Oh, no, oh no, please not the copper right now
of course back here
ah
He's nader appreciate the illuminati there
God damn boy
Hey
Out of the car chloe you're gonna be late, so lovely. Thanks. Thanks for the ride
Shit, thanks. Don't use that Sarcastic tone with me young. It's in pretty
Does she not have a school bang don't you have school bags in school? Why don't you get her bricks hello black how?
Cool. It's good to be back. I'm enjoying this ah
This Kisame Oregon looks beautiful. I actually want to go just from this game
The sun is always low keep that orange beautiful feel I love day
What is that stage a stash a sad-ass - I?
Missed the whole time reverse thing or whatever I guess. I don't really need it anymore
Hey, Chloe. Oh
Hey, Elliot, wait. What happened to your face?
Do you need to go to the nurse or something what this?
You should see the other guy or his ball true that right you had a hell of a night I
mean
People are talking about it. How do people know exactly is talking shit about me. You know
Haters on Social media dab on great. I wish I could tell everyone to just Kennel life
so
How about the tempest?
Blackwell theater at its most pretentious. Yeah, totally I know it's gonna be lame, but I was thinking
Do you want to go together tomorrow?
Maybe I
Try to make it a role not to go to school any more than I have to
Right sitting in the back row and making fun of the drama kids might not suck, right
that's
Totally what I was thinking
Alright. See you in camp. Yeah for sure
Good luck gay boy
Keep breathing your book
about Chemistry loser
Gotta track down stuff to pick up my DVD I've still got time before class
All right, we got steph here with a DVd hey. Yeah, I'm at the picnic tables with in with Amaya Michael. Oh my why
A picnic table, huh looks like over here in it
DvD DVD. I'm Gonna get my DVD DVD DVD DVD DVD DVD DVD?
Wait another if I had known the celestial avenger was bloodied. I would have totally given him my potion
It was a skill challenge ocean wouldn't a worked
Skill Challenge replace the Indian school me play. You wouldn't understand I
Used to play with my friend Max
It's been a long time though
Cool
Got my DVD
one blade Runner director's cut coming right up ah
Sweet good old blade one right?
Keep it. I'm just glad someone here appreciates the classics you even asked for the director's cut which took out the shitty voice
Oh, yeah, replaced it with his sweet dream sequence. No home life ever real life
That's my motto
They added this bit that they shot from another movie the gamer where there's a fucking unicorn
You're asking me didn't you two go out last night or was it just like a friend thing
and
Harrison Ford had they wanted to change the story and make it more obvious
what was going on so they made Harrison Ford record these voiceovers and
He really didn't want to do it and so he just made them as poorly as possible just so they wouldn't actually add them in
But it's really funny. You should look it up cuz he's so bad I
Wonder what's going to happen over here?
What's it to you? We're not I don't answer. I already remember that question why do you want to know?
Steph has a crush
Chloe you should join her game
Yeah, I don't have fifty hours right now
Thanks to that
We're at the end of the campaign so it'll only take like 20 minutes. What else have you got to do before class?
Sure, why don't we place them what the hell game on nerds?
Here's a character sheet you are an Elf Barbarian
Nice, I could totally see myself as an Elf Barbarian. I know I'm good
All right, let's get started
You are both famous heroes in the kingdom of a burn on a once peaceful win now way to waste by the bloodthirsty
Raiders of the Black well
Alone you will fought your way through the raider camps seeking their warlord leader Durga Ron Dermer
As you enter the final camp bloodied and weary you see your fellow hero approaching from the opposite Direction
I raise my staff she's already crow. I am elements
Wizard of the Third Circle Foremost Advisor to King Tiberius and sworn defender of Avenue
Hahaha, don't reduce your character Munda Magette, okay?
I'm an Elf Barbarian named
Jet
columnist yeah, calla, Mastiha
What super into it?
The two he rolled on
Le Monde narrows his eyes at the Elf in front of him and says
I am here to defeat Durga Ron the unscarred in the name of King Tiberius
What makes you think you are worthy to fight alongside me bitch, please I?
once made a man kebab
let's play excess play the actual game your precious king Tiberius everything he knows about fighting, so
Aleman, what makes you think you are worthy to fight alongside me
You gave her that Elf Barberi I did
Lm on Valve's deeply
I've heard of you in the Castle King Tiberius owes you his life
It's an honour to fight Alongside
damn straight
You stupid at a three-way crossing to your left the raiders training ground to your right their prison camp
Straight ahead an enormous ostentatious. Tent that could only belong to Durga Ron Dermer
Which way do you go? Well to straight ahead right? We're supposed to kill the door dude
Elliman Frowns
The Raiders could have some good loot at the training ground and surely it is our duty to free all those prisoners
Your choice Newbie I just want to go to Durga Dawn. Where do you wish to go?
But fuck it. Let's say that goddamn. It's time to free some peeps. Let's go to the prison Camp
You behold the field of standing iron cages each imprisoning a human Villager
calling out for you to free them only a small elderly dragon can is keeping watch he notices you and
Terror Runs into one of the few empty cages and locks himself in ah poor little guy
What's a dragon king Dragon Kin are like little dragon people. They're assholes. I bet he has all the key well
He is holding a bunch of keys
Buddy shit face get out of there
The Dragon can hops up and down shaking his ring of keys at you. He shouts in a strange language
Whatever. He's saying
Probably isn't flattering got any useful spells in that robe of yours nothing that wouldn't blow up the cage and everything in it
Intimidating why don't you try that that's a skill I have
Can I do that? I want the little bastard to shit his pants you can try
What do you say listen up? You little lizard unfortunately? He doesn't speak common which means he can cast
Communication on the Dragon Curve well, this is happening really now. He can understand every word you say
Time to work some real magic. So this is called a skill challenge. Where you try to use
I know what this is I grab the bars of the cage and lean in nice and close
He steps back his scaly skin quivering in fear
What do you say?
Dragons are pussies
Meat puppet, I wiggle my hand
Hey, Dragon King guy
Want to become my meat puppet how it works is I shove my arm up your ass. Oh
He doesn't seem to like that idea
Neither do I
The Dragon Ken pleads with you, please don't harm me tall one, but I cannot give you ki
Burger on much taller and Meaner than you
You're short. I say, but you can always get shorter
Give me the key or I'll chop off your legs and beat you to death with oh wow okay?
Dragon King Towers before you looking left and right
He opens his jaws, and you think he's about to yell for help
I interrupt his yell by shoving my axe into the cage pinning his head to the bars without hurting him then I say the following
This is going to be good. Here's what's up? I'm going to carve the skin from their bones
Hey, then
I'm going to turn your skin into a little leather
Handbag that I'll shoved your skinless body into so I can carry it around with me wherever I go
That way the next time some asshat refuses to give me a key
I want I can pull your body out and show them. What happens. How does that sound?
Wow, that was nice. I'm going to give you a
+10 bonus to Charisma
go ahead and rinse my
pool of Urine Collects under the elderly Dragon Ken as
Hands trembling it hands you the keys then it dies oh
killer
Go team
Why don't you start unlocking the prisoners?
I'm on it as you free them the prisoners run away from you in fear
That's next
Alright, let's just cut it a 10. I don't have to mess around too much wait
Have you forgotten the training camp this potential loop there?
How did I miss that I live for loot let me pick again I?
Live for loot. Oh get out of here
Alright training around then. Loot sounds good. Let's go to the training ground and kind of enjoying
This is weird sweet upon arriving at the training ground you are spotted by a heavyset
ORc who immediately shouts and points there are dozen raiders on the training field all of whom raised their weapons and charged
Okay
So what do we do? I guess gurgles acid blasts our goals?
And you're up a wave of acid that washes over the charging orcs every Raider suddenly starts screaming and writhing in pain
there's a
Sweet-And-sour kind of smell as the Flesh melts off their bones like warm candle Wax
Holy shit, you see why I haven't really needed a partner the heavyset Orc Sergeant still remains
He runs at you swinging a massive war hammer. Oh, you're are you supposed to roll in shit
Paid it'll clean okay. Let's end this fatal cleave
You swing your great axe down
Ord with both hands the Orc blinks then splits open like a hot dog bun fuck yeah. I'm awesome at this game
It's going well
What about the loot well as the training ground is now a roiling pit of acid. Yeah, good job
It's unlikely any loot survived. Hey
Don't worry Allemande guy, we all make mistakes
Dora
What's next?
let's just get the tenth time you've
attained time to find Dirt Dirt dirt whoa raiders of the Black well
sitting comfortably
Thrown. He's a huge red-eyed minotaur swabs in a fine black clock gripping a two-handed
Sword that's easily six feet long his laughter bellows, whoa
Uri lands, and people are already mine your deeds hear me nothing your kingdom was weak
You are weak. What an asshole?
I cast dials cataclysmic cone of fire
The fire fizzles out on contact derp girl and laughs again holding up his right arm to show off his
Bracer of fire and music oh my God yes, yes playin man living all of my battle spills our firebase you just use the acid
Yeah, which someone used unnecessarily to show off for Chloe callum asteya
What'll it be?
man a Minima a man an elation strike
Annihilation strike that sounds bosses fuck. Oh she's role. Thank you one
As you take your first step you trip on a rock
Collapsing onto the ground and a clingy jumble of metal your axe swings widely to the side
Mikey Roller reflex Save oh
No, three your axe strikes elements leg
legs plural severing both feet at the ankles oh
You hit him she hit him
My feet Durga Ron Moves toward the Crippled oh, no
This was my best boss. You didn't tell me my character might die
Durga Ron approaches stomping his bloody hoods stomp
Stomp stomp this is all my fault
Sort of what should I do?
All right jump in front of elam on wow
Thanks, Chloe. I mean thanks LMs. Yeah, okay, okay?
Come on. Bring it. He charges thrusting madly with his great sword
Shit, no, you're the worse at Rolling Dodge his thrust fails
Turgor and laughs as he impales you on his blade
Correcting you high into the air
Seriously, I can't do anything with that stupid bracer
I'm sorry Chloe. Hey, I chopped your feet off
We're even know your strengths draining away as durga ron lifts you higher into the air
It hurts like hell
What do you do?
For his arm bring my axe down onto his arm the one with the fire racer thingy oh
Brilliant you'll have to roll high to hit
You're almost dead come on. Hi Ron
You bring your axe down in a wicked chop severing his eyes
His bracer of fire immunity claims to the ground I cast dig no me's fire strike a flame
a flaming spear
in the chest
Incinerating him completely from the inside out
Lm on the
Ron is defeated, but your wounds were too great
Oh, I'm afraid Cal Mastiha is Dead Done. Done -
Really feel sad right now
Another to have died a hero
then live as a coward
That was fun check out what I drew
Mikey's got serious drawing skills. No, it's pretty bad to be honest, but that's
That's cool. That was fun. I really enjoy that yeah, I was super fun adventure with you anytime. Oh, we'll see
Thanks for the game nerds. What about the DVD is she not steph did I just do all of that for nothing?
Yeah, it is. Steph. I need my fucking DVD
Dude, that's the third time out or know everything
Wait, which one?
DVD check okay, so we got the DVD chemistry class
Joy look up beautiful this school as well. How can you complain?
Stop complaining about everything
Fuckin Play D&D before school it sounds amazing
What the hell?
What have you got here twitch?
YouTube call me that truenorth a jock so dumb. He makes jocks of bad
guess Nathan Prescott made the shit list oh
Wow, oh really? It's a really weird crap press. I it's not yours. Give it back. I hate that you're on the team now
You're such a loser
Guys no need to fight. You can both be losers the mute speaks
Whoa, whoa you earn a spot on the squad twitch. You don't have your dad trying to buy off the coach
At least my family pays tuition. How much financial aid is your deadbeat dad need again. Oh
Wow
Dick move Nathan not really lost his job at the shipyard when your dad closed it down
And you want to talk shit to me? We've Nathan alone. Yeah, oh
My God, what's wrong with her face? I'm gonna. Do you a favor?
You can't be a part of the team to be into this stupid crap at the same time
No, don't do it. You're a piece of shit. I am going to kill you
Isn't that what you're doing? All right? Fuck it the only way to stop a bully is to be aggressive
I've got to put drew down
Back off idiot what the hell did you just say to me?
Leave now or else. I'll beat your ass should be standing up for Nathan, Prescott
Congrats you've actually got me feeling sorry for Arcadia Bay's most spoiled brat that's how much of an asshole
You're being right now
You're such a crazy freak mind your own business okay, so we got one wrong
When Nathan goes crying to lourdes Prescott everybody here will be stuck doing sensitivity seminars all week
Did I fuck up? I think I fucked up?
No game, huh, Chloe oh
That sucks. I wanted to help him
Much to put together oh no, oh team twitch for your own good
Shit next time mind your own business
But Malcolm. Yeah, are you alright?
Thanks for sticking up for him people think just because of his family
Is that the guy everything okay here? Oh no? No problem skip?
Guess you need security at schools, huh?
goddamn
God damn, all right. We got text from Mom glad we talked me, too
All right, let's enter
Jesus what the fuck are you wearing? Oh good? You're here. She's snow white oh
God, what's happening? Now? I thought I had chemistry class I
Do beseech you
Chiefly that I might set it in my prayers
What is your name?
Miranda oh
My father I have broke your hest to say so good admired Miranda indeed worth what's dearest in the world
Many a lady I have eyed with best regard and many a time have listened
many a time the harmony of their tongues
I
Listened to Aidan you're killing me. You've had weeks to be off-book
Sorry, Mr.. Keaton. No don't apologize to me apologize to your scene partner
Who's been very accommodating and to your other fellow actors and most of all to yourself, Mr.
Keaton sorry to interrupt, but does this look better? I had my mom take it in a bit?
Rachel looks awesome. I don't know about that. This is getting as surreal as last night. Oh, that was Rachel
Oh looking good Rachel
Exquisite Rachel as Always, Mr.. Keaton
I'm still having trouble with my affections are then most I have know him. Why am I here good leer man?
I mean does she really mean that
Especially because I just straight-out told her I've been banging all the ladies, huh?
Yeah, that is hard. We've talked about that line forever
We need a fresh perspective. Oh, I see we're Gonna Give feedback the question is
Are Miranda's feelings of instant passion for ferdinand just inexperienced and dramatic circumstances?
Or has she actually just met the love of her life
What do you think oh, God I think you?
Are the one that's spread all the rumors, and I'm gonna say Miranda sand is an idiot because falling in love is stupid
What is she 12?
Yeah
Actually she's about 15, so your point. Whoever you are about being an idiot or being naive is well-taken
huh, glad
There's a safe. Oh no I have first period ImproV with a class full of Freshmen now
Where'd you get it done door?
I'm just kidding that asshole really clocked you it wasn't a big deal. I'll just be a minute, okay
so
Why am I here again? Yeah? You need to go to chemistry belt for me. I think it's in my bag over there
Why does everyone make me get stuff for them?
Yeah
sure
Okay, get the belt don't say any stupid shit and don't like fall down
Rachel looks so happy
Raquel Raquel Okamoto Urban virtual Spells Raquel labelle
Castle go give this to Rachel now. I thought I had to go to client
I thought it said pet baits a pope right PP petit petit better path
Rachel is this your belt. Yes. Thank you
I really like your costume. Thanks so did you bring flowers for my dressing room?
I guess I owe you. I'll hold you to that. Oh
Let you finish changing now. Oh
Chloe Price Rachel Amber last night was amazing
I'd never seen firewalk live
pretty Fierce show
We'll have to do it again to tell the truth. I went to bed last night wishing it never had the end
But then I thought why why does it have to end?
Maybe it doesn't have to end exactly
on a little field trip oh
She's the girl that went missing that's rachel. Oh my I'm so slow
so they had like a love interest I
was born to ditch I
Hoped you'd say that no about that. I
That is a hell of a battle scar - I'm gonna cover it up with some makeup. Maybe
Are you kidding? This is a badge of honor?
respect
Respect let's not black brother ring. Sorry
Okay, so ya know I'm really slow
Took me a while to understand what that I didn't read anything about the game like I just was jumped into it
I didn't know the context of anything
You sure you don't want to just grab the bus or nope if we're Gonna. Go road. We're doing it, right
Are they gonna go to their spot?
Where does this thing go - Jeff town? Jesus Christ? Maybe we'll end up in Seattle
It's in Seattle south from
It's pretty
Hey, what are we skip class? I guess rachel wants me to pull up a chair maybe one of these crates
things Heavier than it looks
Why don't you sit down? Why do they keep these open all right?
Chloe you're on a freakin train with Rachel Freakin Amber just say fucking play it cool
Is this nervousness? Oh God is that what this feeling is?
Wish Max were here so I could ask
Should I make small talk is that what people do?
Nailed it. What is wrong with you what you're acting nervous
So it's kind of weird that we're hanging out
You mean because I don't hang out with anyone, and I don't have any friends you have friends. Oh I used to friend
Singular her name is Max, but she left for greener more Northern pastures
That sucks
Hey, So I
Want to say thanks for pulling you out of school. No, dummy. Thanks for last night
If you hadn't shown up
Assholes abound in Arcadia Bay
I owe you
That's for sure then a real city a kiddy event. Why you came along. Are you suggesting? I should need a reason to ditch school?
Why are you ditching school? I bet you're wondering what we're doing the thought occurred yeah, well I?
wanted some company
That's it
It's a fucking go anything beats another second in Blackwell. You really hate it there. Don't you you don't?
Right what reason would Rachel amber have for hating Blackwell academy?
Your high school royalty you don't know me
Yet, oh
Totally gonna get to know each other. Let's do something fun. Oh, and what is that exactly?
V cards been punched Rachel. I'm sorry wow
Too far well, I don't know
Okay, something fun. I'm all yours. This is so awkward and a lie
What I think we should play too true. Okay fine. Yeah, I got it. It's a game where each person
Oh my God three facts about themselves two of which are the truth and one of which is a lie
Right and then the other person has to guess which is which
Sounds fun. You're on
I'll start first. I'm ambidextrous. What does that mean?
second I was born in New York the land of Fashion and Broadway to
Which I will one day return when my heinous exile here in Arcadia Bay comes to an end, New York, huh, I've never been
Not a world traveler not yet at least
If you could travel anywhere, where would you go russia? We were playing a game dude
Katmandu
One day, I'm going to climb everest
And I thought moving away from Arcadia Bay was ambitious
Okay, what's your third thing?
my third thing
Two truths and a lie you say three things right, I'm a leo meow
Okay, she's definitely a leo okay, so ambidextrous born in New York and a leo
Gotcha I don't know what ambidextrous is which is the lie
New York you see more like a cali girl to me
Damn price, not bad
Long Beach in fact West Coast is the best got it. I've only ever lived in Oregon, so
Nothing to compare it to I guess
then we'll have to change that one day won't we
Are you saying we should run away your turn price first fact right?
something about myself
Should I start things off with a lie or with the truth?
Or should I cheat
Let's see how good. She really is at this game
Huh, sad to say this since you're a leo and all but I'm allergic to cats. Are you now swear
You still want to be a pirate when I grow up I kind of still do
I
Love science seriously, I think neil degrasse tyson is the shit
You're Hella mysterious chloe price
Hella
Who says that it's a cali thing
Anyway, I think I have your number
Of course you wanted to be a pirate
sail the open Seas
Uncle Swash
Plunder Secret Treasure did I mention my love of booty
So pirate obviously true
Maybe you'd like to be my first mate. Oh, are you accepting applications considering it?
All right, what's the say next okay? You say you love science, but you are failing chemistry
You're saying failing chemistry means. I hate science. Well, or that black well doesn't inspire your best work
Well sure, it's not for everyone I get that
Anyway, school sucks, but you love science. I'm gonna say true
Which brings me to your alleged camp? Why don't you not believe that alleged?
I'm calling why why is that? I mean maybe you're allergic
That passed by your locker a few times, and I've seen that old photo of a cat. You keep in there
His name was Bongo. He was a gift from my Dad who names their cat bongo
Yeah
My dad dug two years ago. I thought everyone knew that
While I was talking about you ken
Bongo oh
My God of course. That's what you meant. I'm so sorry
Definitely, so if my math is correct you told me two truths and one lie
what you expected me to cheat winners make their own rules chloe you are crazy good at this game a
Lifetime of studying the human condition. We both did oh my God
No, I mean you're really good at this game. We have the same score
We did the same imagining. What creeps chloe price out?
when your dad is the district attorney I guess lying is
something you're used to
seriously
Seriously, I know who to call if I need to get out of a ticket then
That I have a right of my own probably they expected you to cheat, and then she's still got it, right
But she figured out that you cheated and that's why she's like. Oh, you're crazy good
Trusting you you played the game and not everyone would admit to wanting to be a pirate
But I patches are so cool. Yeah, you could need one delicious I
guess
You opened up a lot. That's all oh my God. It's not a big deal
Yeah, it's really not a big shit to break it to you
But chloe price is not exactly renowned throughout Arcadia bay as a bastion of trust and empathy
I'm just not really into touchy-feely shit
but I
Feel like I can trust you
Yeah, I got on this train with you
therefore you are
You Gonna kiss her one?
Wouldn't mind listening to some music
Hey, you want to listen? That's cute
nice
Really like how they do the music in this makes it so it more immersive
It's cool. I'm gonna have to talk over them. I
Don't want to ruin all the moments just kittens leave
Well Bracelet. I've had it. I guess since I was a kid in Long Beach
It reminds me that there's more to experience out there than just Arcadia Bay
Maybe one day. I'll go back to Long Beach or
Anywhere, but you maybe sooner than later
Me, too
Arcadia Bacon suck a bag of dicks
Sometimes I feel like I've gotten a reason to stay. It's getting a little drag that I think we surprised Chloe
if one day
I'm just out of here. Oh, maybe she didn't die. She just lifeless
Check it out. We're here
Where are we going what where is here jump and find out? Did you say jump jump?
fucking
broke bofur legs and the seasons over
Pretty that's how you run, right?
Please don't make me talk to that old lady down there
some lame shit
Are we are we out by the pier not the pier the lighthouse?
I think we are I recognize it
Hey
it's actually a pretty nice view glad you approve and
As your reward for making it up here. I have a new game. Oh my God
Another one I like games deal with it. This is when I learned in theater class it's all about improvisation
So far what I've learned about you is that you're into acting lying and playing games
What's your point that you're either full of imagination or full of shit?
Hmm
Let me know when you figure out which one
this game
Involves spying on people from afar
Luckily we've got some high-tech surveillance equipment right here. Let's fire it up
Wow, cool
That blows well shit. Well there was another one that
Was my last quarter you?
quarter 'less damn
Hey, maybe I can macgyver something up. I've been told I'm pretty handy. Oh yeah
Let's see what you got
Bang on it. Maybe a little bit like she did
Sorry about drew oh
That's his bigger brother
Rachel really wants to use this Viewfinder. Huh looks like I might be able to pry it open with the right tool
squirrel
Oh, they're so cute
Get out of your woodland creatures. Have some self-respect I
Thought there might be like a tool there or something
Well really I can go far away and shit
I've been saying sorry all morning. It was really dumb to lock the keys in the car. You've been on me for three hours
Can I borrow a tool hey spare some change?
Sorry, we might have some leftover food, and we're done what no, I'm not
What kind of food?
This place has really gone Downhill hah hah hah hah hah hah hah hah? Hah hah?
There's got to be something freeing about being able to build your home wherever you are. God, whatever is around you
Okay, all right
Whoa, that's badass
Yep, it's official
I'm learning away more ditching school than I ever do in class oh
No, no, no that are a darker turkic
cliche much aww, and oh well
all owl
Okay, well, I thought I'd find a tool down here some shears like that. I
Wonder if I could use this to get the quarter out
Well, take it then I wonder if I could use this to get the quarter out you can only look at it
Scare the Birds as well
Oh my God
The cringe hey squirrels are back everybody and a squirrel is a bag
If max were here she'd probably take a black-and-white photograph and call it
Innocence lost or some shit this black wall guy sure liked founding stuff. That was already there
Founders Keepers, I guess
Where do I go? Maybe I go down here I?
Don't Wanna head down there. I don't want to head down there just yet
I don't want to adam Wanna add them on the head down there. Just yet. I just need to feel it proud of black
They're there but there but never Jeff looks like this one might actually be working
I'm thinking about prying open that Viewfinder got a knife on you a knife. Yeah
my Mom took mine, uh
No
how about a
Nail file oh so she had it all agree
Yeah, I guess you could stab someone with a nail file. Oh
Right sure let's try it
Chloe brass I heard some shit from
All right
Come on. Let's get this party started. Oh, oh damn it. It always looks so easy in the movies
Wonder if I can find something sturdier to use like a deal like mmMm, man, laughs yeah
Yeah, manomet. Yes
All right, how about this one hMM?
Yeah, let's take away the memory of someone who donated a chair
stealing a dedication plate takes persistence and Mandel's
oh
That's so sweet
Haha, why don't you just talk to him?
first got power activate
All right, we did it
Now put it in the other one and we can play this game
Inside the game yeah play the game inside of the game not to brag
But I got a boast so I'll let you do it for me chloe price
You are truly the Viewfinder whisperer. I stand in all of your powers
look
cute Rachel smells like Jasmine is she smelling me right now -
Really should have showered this morning
All right, here's the game
You find some people for us to spy on and then you and I will act out what they're saying and thinking
That's it. I do that in my head during like every class see you're a natural
Let's give it a try all right
Let's start with the girl no
we're him
Whoo loving this guy, what's he thinking right now?
Stay away bees. I hope bees don't mistake my shorts for a begonia. I've been pollinated twice this week already
Hmm. What's going on with these two and
The Lord said if thou shalt make a burnt offering of your firstborn son
Who are you talking to dad yeah, son
now lean into the grill and see if the fire started
further
Wow, that was dark too Dark perfect Dark
Okay, and then we have what the what hey, what do you say we barbeque some squirrels when we're done here
God, you just have the best ideas Ted
They totally stole my third grade art project
Wow, you made that yet? You tell it does have a certain give zero fucks quality that I recognized 10
All right these two all right. Let's see
Why do we always hold hands like this didn't you tell me you are ambidextrous. What's happening straight? I said I was am bisexual
So you can have sex with both of your hands exactly want to see only if you let go of my hat first
Have I not clicked on everyone yet? This is fun. Who's next oh
We're gonna see something bad. I think didn't mean to hog the Viewfinder
Is that her mom oh jackpot?
that's her mom isn't it's makeout session in 3 2 1
Nailed it Tim. They are really going at it. Oh
Honey, I think we use the vibrating bed for too long. I'm totally seeing double Rachel. Oh
Are you all right the dad?
Excuse me last I checked you're supposed to be chloe price yet
We've been ditching now for hours, and we haven't even gotten wasted yet. That's got to be against some school ditching Rule. I
Don't know I might still be hungover from last night
Wrong answer you don't ask a girl out and then and then not buy her drink
Maybe they left some wine the other couple
But it's pretty obvious. What just happened there
They have a bottle of wine
Let's steal it
Okay
Or we could go try to find a liquor store instead no
you shouldn't bring alcohol to a public park if you're not willing to share it with everybody right and
Fuck it. I just want to take something that's not mine. All right. I'm going in try to keep up
That was so cool. Can we help you?
Oh my God
What?
Take the wow take the one stick to act it take what shit talk about committing to a performance
Better Act yo, Inc
Thank God, please this girl is in trouble. Go get help I
Need to get these two to focus on Rachel, so I can swipe the wine, okay. We got this waiting for go
I've seen this kind of thing before this woman clearly has a wound that needs to be sterilized
Do you happen to have any alcohol? He didn't see a wound look closer in the meantime. I'll search for the booze
Hold on. There's something off about this all right you girls putting us on
Rachel Run
pit Row
So maybe you're acting could use a little work, but at least you committed to the performance
Thanks
Thanks, I
Could use a drink after trying to keep up with you. Oh
God
She's really drinking a lot I
Am excessively sober yeah, right?
Okay, guess. We're leaving now
Uh-Huh, okay?
All right great
That's an awkward looking tree
Very cute. I really love how the atmosphere is in this game. I think it's why I enjoyed
And this squirrels of course gotta appreciate them you know
Hey check this out
What oh yeah, this is where we used to go
How were they gonna get back am I the only one thinking about this? I'm a little worried
That's pretty
Great. It's a pile of trash
Yeah an awesome pile of trash. Let's explore. You have fun Chloe
I'm Gonna go sit down
Rachael's been acting kind of standoffish ever since we left the park
What's her deal?
I've heard that actors are moody, but wow Rachel. I'm not moody. I just need some space
Is that all right with you, okay?
actually
No, I thought we were having a great day together. Why are you acting like this all of a sudden?
I'm not acting like anything. I just want to be left alone right now
No, I don't understand you. Can't just turn on me for no reason
I'm sorry turn on you. I guess I forgot. It's always about how you feel isn't it sad. Chloe's fucking sad again
Maybe you should try giving a shit about other people for once. Oh, are you serious right now?
Okay, maybe we should give her some space. I still have no idea what's going on with Rachel, but
Apparently she gets smashy when she's Angry I
Can work with that?
score it's a perfect baseball bat
Sure, we're how it's done check it out. I
Don't always drink beer
But when I do I prefer drinking it next to an old toilet
What?
That was the worst thing I've ever seen you didn't even smash the body
Sure, she takes it and beats the shit out of her
Are you kidding me?
I know you're the school princess and all with the da-daddy in the perfect grades and all that perfect little
Victoria chases kissing your perfect ass but seriously
Fuck you
great
I'm leaving again. See you around chloe great. You can't leave watch me
Get me chill wait
Don't go
Why not I?
Robbed you because because I don't want to ruin this the way I ruin everything else in my life
And what is this exactly I?
mean
Fuck are you actually going to make me say it say what exactly?
you know like a
friendship
but
more
I
know
weird right
it's just
Today was the best day. I've had since
since my dad died and
When I almost ruined it just now the way I ruin everything it made me realize
Whatever is going on between us is special
Come on say something
Chloe I'm sorry. I am really really sorry
but
oh
Why not because I can't I know it isn't there, but it's how it is
Goodbye Chloe
I don't know how to get out of here
This way she's Gonna. Dye her hair blue. I think so
Fuck shit
I'm gonna need my cat ears for this one now it got it. Just got serious
Mom, just texted me, and I don't even care just text her I
guess I can
Air it is
The sign is going to Smash smash us man. Dip it better be okay?
Or pay no, she's fake you can't take your eyes off her who else do I know who fits that description?
Rachel you fuck off Rachel Rachel fuck off man
hard on camera smacks
You take a million pictures of us and not one of them showed that you were gonna leave when I needed you bust
fuck cameras
wait
This needs to be right?
Okay
That completely off goddamnit
If you want to rip a family apart from the inside, it's important to bring the proper
Fuck you, David. I see they're all representing the people in her life
Damn, she's really messing that shit up
Okay
Maybe it's you chloe. Maybe you're the one responsible. Have you thought of that oh
Said his old car
I guess it is, huh
Smash press f to pay respect
It's a mogwai shit going on. I like it
oh
or thing
damn
My my best friend when I was that age
Mom died and at one of the things I regret most is not being supportive enough
Doing more you core that person. I don't know I
Don't know. What do you do?
What's the right thing to do because you're not real?
I'm not
She's going on. Yeah, what is going on? I?
Guess I did that
Yeah, you did
kiddo look on the bright side would ya
What bright side?
You made a new friend today
not really
I don't feel drunk
I say that was some fight the lover's quarrel you might say she
Nearly took your head off
What is happening right now?
I'm well confused man. What do you care? Sorry sweetheart? I guess I'm getting into your personal business
What's past is prologue, and shit sometimes people need you though?
Is that Rachel?
Even when they don't admit it
Because feelers are complicated
Oh my God
Bucho
nothing watches happen
She fell asleep to you sis
Yeah, it might be time to call your mom
I'm sure if you tell her what happened, she would understand you know
That's got to be so rough to see
Plus she didn't charge her phone. It should be dead by now. What kind of a magic battery does she have in that thing
Right just me thinking this way hmM
It's Rachel still there. No, it's a bird there were someone walking Jesus
guess just walk home, huh a
lot of
sequences over and over and over and over and over and over, and it doesn't feel like I'm playing it just like plays itself and
I really have to pee
She's still there
You promised you would text your mom can't you just say hey? I'm fine. I'm hanging out with Rachel
You came. Well, I'm glad
hey, I
couldn't let the day and with
whatever it this afternoon was
Chloe I want to talk to you about something, but I
Don't know how to talk about this
You don't have to tell me anything you don't want to
You remember that guy that we saw under this tree? Oh, wow what a shocker the ones who were making out that
Was my dad okay, so what's the dad not the mom all right?
and that woman was
Definitely not my mom oh
the Worst part is
I'm not surprised I
Felt like my dad's been lying about something for awhile, and what are you doing that situation? Do you tell your mom about it? I?
didn't know what it was so
When I saw, he got a text from an unknown number
Asking him to meet I thought I thought I could catch him or something. Oh, that's why she wanted to leave
I'm so sorry Rachel. I
don't I
Don't know what to say neither do I?
Chloe I love my Dad I
Love him, and I never want to see his fucking face again
when my dad died I
Was so mad at him
For months I felt
wrong because
Half the time, I thought of him. I wanted to scream
and the other half I
forgot
Forgot, but anything had changed
It's silly, but I've carried this photo around with me for years
It's from Mount hood
My dad took me hiking there when I was ten and it started raining
And I fell and broke my arms three miles from the car I
Remember screaming like I was gonna Die but my dad
He carried me down the Mountain I
still remember the smell of his coat, and oh call me was in the sound of his voice and
It's easy just comfort her
No, he was just so strong. You know what why'd you let me pick that day?
No, one's ever safe. Yeah
here
Chloe I owe you an apology
Hey, we were both kind of the queen of shitty no, I mean it
whatever's going on between us, it's
Intense and new and awesome, and you had the courage to tell me that you feel it, too
And I treated you like shit
courage I don't know if I'd call it that or like blind desperation and
maybe a slight buzz from that whine
I just want you to know
I'm lucky that you were with me today
You're a badass chloe price what?
Remember that biker asshole who wouldn't let you into the mill
You talked your way right past him sure did you saw that and there's skeevy douchebags who followed you upstairs you?
Dropped that one guy with the need of the balls
Honey because you showed up at the last minute and what about drew?
when he was picking on Nathan
You got right in his face and called him out and almost got punched in the head
see
You're the real thing Chloe I
Don't know anyone like you plus you came along with me no questions asked
Well, I don't really need a good reason to Ditch school. I
Guess tomorrow there'll be hell to pay
My mom might skip grounding and just go straight to the death penalty and my dad
Will definitely punish me with
Fuck your dad
Fuck him
What I wouldn't give to leave this place and never look back
What's stopping us?
ice
Are you serious? There's nothing keeping me here not anymore?
Do you so if I came to you tomorrow and told you to pack your bags? I'm serious
Let's do it. Chloe. Let's leave this place forever
Okay, really
damn um
Can I borrow your lighter? Oh shit? She's not gonna burn it?
Thank you
damned our use of burning fanciful I
Know why I keep drinking. I had got a piece, so fucking bad
Come on
Oh, no
We should probably
Well, neighbor Island. I'm not responsible for
What is happening I?
Think this is the end thank God I cuz I have to be so bad oh
Yeah, we talked to this guy later, didn't we
Dan that's not a bad fire
all the video games takecare plays in Oregon
I forgot their names this one obviously
Second son or whatever was called fuck. I forgot and then the fire watch
When she's still there
Oh, I think she saw it may be interesting
Life is strange before the storm it all makes sense before the storm before the first season. It's a prequel. God damn
I'm so stupid
Okay, well that was it. I'm gonna cut that before I pissed myself you attacked. Okay 61% agree with me
I was kind to joyce y-you mean 40% were mean goddamn. That's mean
Most people defended Nathan that's good and most people told Rachel. You are more than just friends, okay?
Cool. Yeah
damn, so that's a the next episode ah
So can we already play these that's awesome. No. It's coming soon fuck
Ah I was so happy. I was like. Oh shit. I got two more episodes
Alright, well that was life a strange episode 1 before the storm. Hope you guys enjoyed it. I loved it
I thought it was so good. I hope you guys enjoyed it and
I can't wait to share the other 2 episodes with you guys. Thank you so much for watching
It really means a lot and so happy I can do these and share these moments with you
Like why'd you guys are long for the journey that's it for me for now however
So I'm going to end this with the squad Fam Jiu Jitsu out remember - my name is Jeff